when people come across enemies they
trip out and certainly in australia we
make so many laws where we just don't
allow any
anyone to face anything that's of a
difficult nature are we becoming less
resilient as a society
there's no question about it there's no
question about it i posted something on
facebook the other day about debate
and i said one of the greatest things
in life is debate you know i i'd much
rather
watch a two-hour debate
of the hitchens brothers debating god
the existence of gods
three hours on youtube the two brothers
one's a christian one's a catholic
believes in god
the other wasn't an atheist doesn't
believe in god you watch that three-hour
debate you're going to learn more from
that three-hour debate then
you would go into college taking a
semester in theology
because debate is what we need and by
the time you're done watching that
debate you're going to walk away and
you're going to say
you know what i don't agree with what
hitch said as an atheist and and i
i'm an atheist but i don't i don't think
that argument was that strong because
his brother said this but you know his
brother said something about god the
existence of god and virgin mary and
jesus
i kind of like what chris hitchens said
to that but you know what i'm walking
away saying
i used to not believe there's a god i
think there is a god
i think there's more of a god today than
i thought yesterday or you're going to
walk away you're going to say
you know i still believe in god i don't
know if i believe in it as much as i do
cried because we had debate right here's
what debate does the beautiful power of
debate is the following
put a democrat on a republican let him
debate put a christian
an atheist put a a person that believes
in pro-life pro-choice
guns no guns military no military war
to protect the country no war world
peace
somebody that believes in apple somebody
that believes in droid somebody that
loves soccer somebody
loves football put him in a room let him
debate
let us watch it you know what it does to
the audience it's the craziest thing
so all the extremes who are far right
or far left what a great debate does
it brings us inner it doesn't bring us
all the way in it doesn't even get us to
tip to the other side
but it just gets our extremes to be a
little bit smaller
and smaller and the further we get to
the center the more we get to the center
the more reasonable we are
and the more reasonable we are the
easier it is for us to
communicate with each other and deal
with each other and understand each
other's differences
but what looks like that's happening
right now with all the sensitivity and
the pierce morgan and all this other
stuff
we're eliminating debate and it's gonna
make the next generation dumber
unfortunately